faut-il fermer les frontières la russie
la mongolie népal pays frontalier à la
chine ont fermé leurs frontières
depuis début février la france étant un
pays frontalier à l'italie la question
se pose aussi
oui ou non répond des petits chéris
marine le pen a donné son avis regardez
à votre adn et digoin d'autres concerts
et alien bien sûr mais il faut des
contrôles de toute façon je veux dire la
frontière en réalité c'est un élément de
protection des populations quelle que
soit la situation parce que on parle de
l'épidémie en italie mais on ne parle
pas
de tous de tous les gens qui traversent
la frontière sans être du tout contrôler
parce qu'ils sont en situation
clandestine tous les pays quasiment qui
sont aux côtés d'un pays où existe une
épidémie ferme pour contrôler leurs
frontières tous sans exception sauf une
fois de plus voilà alors oui ou non non
non non non non non alors juste vous
dites non pourquoi
c'est curieux parce que barry nos peurs
on savait qu'ils allaient dire oui après
elle était partie sailly sur la lys et
serait parti sur autre chose
vous vous dites tous non ici sa ceinture
youtube je vais demander aux
téléspectateurs ce qu'ils en pensent que
j'ai envie d'avoir l'avis des
téléspectateurs soit cette question
voilà c'est un bordeaux réduit
non évidemment que non parce que c'est
tellement facile une fois qu'on est
responsable politique de faire un peu de
récupération est bon et moi j'arriverais
ces rations là moi je ferai ça quand on
a aucune et elle a dit qu'aucun même le
contrôle ça n'a aucune base
épidémiologique ou scientifique de la
même façon qu'on a reproché au tout
début d'épidémie rappelez vous vous ne
verrez plus cher à prochaine et ce
besoin de distribuer des tracts et ne
pas te faire de contrôle de température
à l'aéroport c'est exactement la même
chose mais c'est à dire que d'un point
de vue l'épidémiologiste
interrogés les experts pas marine le pen
voit cette mesure on limitera voir la
diffusion du virus
moi je vais vous dire contre si la
pression si vous avez tous répondu là
les mecs vous avez répondu harry ne
serait ce que vous êtes
il est paré pour nous bousculer bois
marine le pen
ces interventions de monsieur serena
l'avait joué les irrigants ça pour ça on
parle d'une époque
la menace est bien réelle à tort parce
qu'il fallait beaucoup plus droit qua
non par ce fait elle est beaucoup plus
loin que ce qu'elle dit ça n'a aucun
sens le mode frontières c'est des zones
qui font ce qu il faut circonscrire ci
est beaucoup plus étriqué qu'un pays bas
quand des villages et la lobaye quartier
des pâtés de maisons donc faut être
encore beaucoup plus jusqu'au boutiste
qu'elle d'alcool en termes de taille ou
de france que ça se joue mais en termes
de quartier ou d'école je suis encore là
parce que les séries mais monsieur qui
sait quelle journée à la radio ça 2010
et non ça sert à rien c'est efficace
moi j'ai arrêté d'écouter cette radio
est la vôtre ou même radio
mais eric naulleau est ce que disent les
spécialistes quand même faut se fier aux
spécialistes dans les questions qui vous
dépasse les contrôles à la frontière ne
servent qu'à intercepté non nommé reste
fermé les frontières
moi je pense pas qu'on ait frontières
c'est pas s'est passé et comment vous
allez le faire demain pour attend même
pour un temps donné demain ou fermer les
frontières n'ont parlé des risques
économiques vous flanquer tout le pays
en l'air et le cas de l'oise l'oise
n'avait pas me le mézois sont en effet
engagés à voyager c'est de la famille
l'efficace il renseigné pourquoi les
gens se posent des questions pour
l'heureux pour tous vents l'on essaye
tous les domaines mais pourquoi les gens
se posent des questions parce qu'on
avait rapatrié des français on les a
confiné 14 jours et en même temps peut
demander d'expérience voilà et en même
temps pardon il ya d'autres personnes
qui venaient de chine et qui ne
subissait pas de contrôle donc c'est
normal que la questionne les gens se
disent pourquoi
ensuite on les déclare ya eu des coeurs
en italie et les gens se sont posé des
questions pourquoi parce qu'on a bu
toute la journée à la télé des gens
passer la barrière italienne et on leur
a dit est ce qu'on vous a contrôlé non
non faut quand même comprendre que les
français se posent la question de la
maladie en italie et donc pourquoi on
les contrôle pas moi je serais pour
baisser quoi le contrôle mais qu'est-ce
que laurent sa ministre ferait
configurer la fraude la virée moroni
mais orléans mais il fait de la
politique non mais québec celui de mai
nous l'avons m'explique que finalement
la le cours d'un virus elles auraient
toutes les mesures mais concrètement
comment votre le tournaisis thierry
poulet peuple et non seulement panamera
et clairement car la france est
peut-être mais quelle plein français se
sont posés sur la vie de bernard laporte
qui écoutent la radio vers la fin du jeu
nicolas dupont aignan vous êtes pour
fermer les frontières où je suis j'ai
demandé alors faut être précis
oui bah oui bon contrôle des frontières
oui selon les destinations je prends un
exemple avec l'italie impossible en
revanche qu à ce qu' il ya des échanges
extrêmement nombreux parce qu'il ya
plusieurs points de frontières et parce
que l'italie a confiné dans une région
les cas en revanche fo lipidique
revendique allie donc vous en revanche
ce qui l'est c'est ça que tu vois le
risque devient actuellement de l'italie
bah oui c'est assez bizarre mais je
finissais nicolas fini c'est fini a dit
jeudi que au début fin janvier
nous aurions pu agir un peu plus vite
même limité les bons vins non remariés
essayons d'être dans la dans le
feuilleton est las vegas que ça une
conséquence on soit dans le curieux long
sur la chine sur la chine les etats unis
ont interdit les vols en provenance de
chine à l'exception des vols ramenant
des américains et aux stopper l'arrivée
de touristes chinois
nous on a les vols air france se sont
arrêtés parce que le personnel allemand
bild son devoir de réserve et on a
laissé des avions venant de chine eux
pendant un mois
des touristes chinois arrivé est la
seule politique avec madame buzyn
c'était de mettre des affichettes pour
dire attention mais je pense qu est ce
que le rayon de jeux pan est ce que vous
auriez fait mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'on
peut rien jean leur fait deux choses
j'aurais supprimer les vols avec la
chine en restreignant les retours
uniquement à nos concitoyens france au
collage chine stopper le tourisme des
chinois que la chance francs d'accord
parce qu'il y avait à fleurier là bas
pas l'italie à l'idée à l'époque et mais
pas l'italie je parle en page de
maintenance comme aussi à l'époque je
vous pas le faire là bas aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il faut vraiment que la mesure
sur mais c'est facile de se moquer mais
joue sur le japon sur la corée du sud
comme le demandent les américains dada
des démocrates américains voyaient un
candidat démocrate qui le demandaient
chambre des représentants donc ça paraît
et beaucoup de pays l'ont fait
deuxièmement ce que le contrôle des
frontières peut avoir un intérêt pour la
traçabilité et j'avais demandé fin
janvier notamment des experts de santé
publique de debout la france qu'on est
un petit documents de traçabilité
il permet aux gens qui arrivent par
exemple même en avion d'italie de dire
où il était pendant les quatorze jours
précédents parce que vous pouvez arriver
très bien de rome et avoir été en
lombardie
trois jours avant c'était un document de
traçabilité qui aurait été rempli dans
les avions comme quand on va aux états
unis ont rempli des documents et qui
permettait d'avoir une mémoire et qui
aidait les services des différents pays
venaient de drones la caisse qu'elle
faisait elle été mis en quarantaine
samedi par exemple on avait un italien
qui venait de rome et qui avait fait
trois jours
le séjour à lombardie là c'est qu'on a
fait c'est ce qu'on a fait avec des
nerfs alors je vais leur faire d'abord
le mérite à ankara 13 non à borat est
non ça s'est passé lors on le vend 6
pourquoi pourquoi ces affaires ne vont
pas tomber les erreurs on est dans la
zone du faux négatifs monsieur
dupont-aignan
c'est à dire que si je vous fais un test
alors que vous êtes peut-être porteurs
du virus
maintenant que je vous fais un test on
et quyen anchois votre nez sur votre
gorge paul zara une chance indicative
négative alors pas aussi vous êtes dans
l'idéologie je vais vous dire pour un
grand nom je suis pas d'orgie de radio
et j'aurais pu vous me dites que l'essai
du point y entre on nous explique que
les tests sont formidables et qui c'est
utile et tout à coup quand il s'agit de
fonds tient ce jeudi pour une défense ne
marche pas noah chi sans frontiérisme
tombeau elle est super content on a
confiné les écoles
la nation la frontière c'est la boutique
ya deux mois j'ai jamais dit qu'il
fallait faire mais c'est fini il faut
contrôler il faut contrôler pas on avait
moins en a que pour le corps merci merci
nicolas dupont aignan est ton sentiment
j'aimerais avoir le sentiment du
professeur mais c'est effrayant
contrôler 100 ou team était
méthodologiquement valide c'est rien
faire un problème en fait jamais rien
connu mais non les experts on a laissé
hors de chine avec des outils milliers
tairai le nom des médicaments aux
métiers à nu les candidatures et des
experts sont d'accord entre eux beaucoup
d'experts qui ont dit qu'on avait laissé
rentrer de chine qu'on peut voir côte
jambes
j'entends c'est chiant d'avoir une
pensée différente ça va rester entre
vous mais vous êtes tous pareils c'est
non pas du tout l'attrait de comptes se
contrarient taurine une franc juste
monsieur ni comment on essaie juste
avoir l'avis de christophe rap cristaux
grave parce qu'il faut bien fermer les
tenants et il ya deux semaines le plan
théorique madame d apaiser la question
c'est une bonne question est quelqu'un
qui n'est pas médecin spécialiste
d'épidémiologie doit se labelliser tout
le monde se la pose c'est une bonne
caisse et ont atterri vers l'île aux
noix le pays le font mais non non non au
collège états unis sont la russie et la
du point nord sont pas on veut pas
répondre
début décembre il a toujours pas
construit son voyez vous êtes dans
l'eagle
on n'a pas dire que les états unis
entend l'appel d'israël israël attend
nous à bas israël est un horrible
pourrait contrôler privé d'important
mais non mais oui mais pourquoi tout ce
petit monde est petit convoqué quel
outil le contrôle il remercie mes
professeurs rap n'est pas jusqu'au bout
la forêt sera vous est-ce que vous
pensez que les pays avaient un rôle aux
frontières ou fermer les frontières
non le contrôle aux frontières avait
déjà été tentée dans d'autres épidémies
il n'est pas efficace il peut retarder
un tout petit peu là compte tenu de la
diffusion ça n'a aucun intérêt est le
vrai problème c'est que nous n'avons pas
d'où si on a réfléchi au scanner on a
réfléchi à examiner les gens etc
c'est extrêmement compliqué à faire il
n'y a pas d'outil validé donc c'est une
fausse sécurité
après ça a une valeur symbolique ça une
valeur politique et donc on s'applique
une espèce de double peine économique il
ya allemand compte et intérêts